joe shoot a random square up there all
right i'm feeling this one up here
you just eliminated the ten thousand
dollar target each target has a cash
prize behind it and whichever one he
shoots last he keeps he could win a
hundred thousand dollars or nothing oh
my gosh all right joe pick this one i
promise it's not the hundred that's a
bold prediction from chandler all right
chandler you're my favorite don't listen
to chandler
oh
we don't want 20. we want a hundred
we're going big we want the big money
you're either gonna walk away with a
hundred grand or like one of these
little numbers now i like this one
let's go joe all right you have a one in
five chance all right for a shot corner
shot
yeah joe oh
all right all right all right you have a
25 chance at 100 000
choose your next shot carefully joe you
got this let's go for the last middle
one
oh let's go joe you're either walking
away with a hundred thousand dollars
four thousand dollars or literally
nothing your entire life depends on this
let's go joke come on joe all right
you have one shot left and can either
win four thousand dollars or walk away
with nothing all right last shot here we
go top one
and congratulations you almost 100 grand
four thousand dollars can still buy you
a lot of candy bars trevor craft 71 if
you complete this maze in under one hour
you get the most insane prize we've ever
given away in mr beast's history what is
it nolan's father's truck
and the timer started now good luck for
now on dashboard let's go come on never
thought i'd hear someone excited with
nonstats truck cars car i like going
fast it barely drives i'm gonna go give
away tens of thousands of dollars so
i'll see you in a little bit i'll be
trying to complete this thank you on the
left is chris chandler and darnia and on
the right is carl nolan and j-man these
two teams are gonna take turns shooting
explosive arrows at each other and
whichever team is on the platform the
longest wins ten thousand dollars let's
go we're gonna do this we got it j man
we got it j men it's your shot
oh
[Applause]
my god no wait did you already fall oh
my god darty has ten thousand dollars
just now in the hands of kristen
chandler
ah that's not bad that's not bad all
right i'm going for chris because he
doesn't know what's going on nolan
what just happened
oh you're bad kid oh my god you're bad
kid delete your whole game
oh
nice
way j-man fell uh
bruh do you just not want to take her in
i ran out of real estate well now you
won't be able to buy real estate if i
die
oh it shot the ground out underneath me
oh it's a 1v1 now
sorry carl
oh
bro
i'm the best it didn't even blow me up
carl i love you jay man we all did it
together wait is this rec room yes you
have until the end of this ad read to
beat this map and if you do i'll buy
your brother a vr setup oh god let's do
this thing rec room is a free online
sandbox game where you can hang out with
your friends playing different games
explore challenge maps and find creative
rooms to entertain you for hours
rackroom is also cross-play and you can
play on ios android xbox steam ps4 and 5
oculus vr and other platforms in the
future that's too many platforms there
is never too many here we go the final
stretch and i've partnered with rec room
to give all of you guys a free mr b
shirt in game all you have to do is
visit the rec center in the next seven
days and claim it oh jimmy i'm standing
next to a sign that says the end then
tell your brother he just got one vr
headset richer
guys scan this qr code or use the link
in description install rec room right
now there's literally no reason it's
free and it's fun to play yuri are you
athletic no not really if you can make
it to the other side of this football
field without dying to these zombies you
went ten thousand dollars oh my god go
go go go hurry who do you think will be
them dingles he's got a whole horde
behind him he's going long first down it
progressively gets harder the further he
goes oh
oh
he's at the halfway point yuri go down
the sideline fury you're going the wrong
way what the heck i'm getting the hell
fight voice the 10 grand is that way
stop going the other direction he's in
the red zone this is where things really
get hard oh my gosh they're swarming him
holy crap
you got it here he goes
oh
oh you died i'm gonna cry myself to
sleep tonight next
forever buddy how's it going i am trying
to tear through this maze as fast as i
can i'm gonna be real with you you've
officially used up half your time but
you're not even halfway done with the
maze oh goodness gravy what is your
favorite youtube channel technoblade i
was gonna cut a hole through the maze
for you but i have bought if you want to
get further in the maze uh just called
technoblade i'm sorry let's head to the
next bit felix do you see these boxes
over here yes i do well now you can't
because you have blindness
oh what now goofy goofers pick a box to
stand behind okay
felix i have now cured your blindness i
can see again shoot one of those yellow
boxes back there
oh oh
oh
we were right beside it you're gonna do
this three more times and for every
single one of them that makes it to the
end you win five thousand dollars in
cash oh my god you're blind again
everybody get out felix take a shot all
the money
please
oh
no
felix you just lost 10 000 but it's okay
if chandler and nolan make it to the end
you can still win 10 grand and you're
blind again all right chandler let's not
split up yeah baby felix they are both
behind the same box just don't pick the
wrong one i'm just going to go for it
for all the marbles 10 grand on the line
this is
it
yeah
congratulations blind him i got this
chandler same box server mute nolan and
chandler no you can't
no dude where are you oh great now i
can't hear nolan talk oh my god let's
see if you trust me felix they're behind
this box on the left that one right
there yeah sure if you believe jimmy
that is i'm gonna hit the one on the
left we're mr beast
he walked in grand felix are you buying
3 300 feastable candy bars or are you
buying a couple thousand mr beast
burgers all of the above and just for
selling out i'm gonna give you an extra
five grand for promoting my companies oh
my god free money
trevor we're back i've changed my
favorite youtuber yeah who's your
favorite youtuber now my favorite
youtubers mr beastgaming are you just
saying this so i'll help you or do you
mean it him and his entire crew i love
them all i believe you follow me trevor
oh my gosh you get an escort
there we go you are now in the final 25
of the map gotcha thank you very much
you have 10 minutes left see you then
i'm so close i can taste it we are about
to play a 10 000 game of hockey gazman
is the leader of team red and master is
the leader team blue team blue sucks
first team to score their leader wins 10
grand have atta boys
macaronis hit it come on drop gob go
all right get on the other side chris
just get on the other side of it this is
in the bag all right all right all right
all right
hit it hit it carl go go go go go
hey jasmine do you not like ten thousand
dollars the choice oh this might be it
this might be it
i'm the best at hockey challenge
while you're in the same call as the
person you just stole ten thousand
dollars from what you want to say dude
i'm so sorry man yo gg master
all right trevor hello i did it
congratulations on winning a terrible
truck it really is bad i hope you guys
liked the video subscribe to my jimmy
gave away my truck i guess i'll walk to
work